hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar expanding
erf
equivalent number of reference
fluorophore value assignments for
quantitative flow cytometry
more colors and smaller particles i am
jennifer woods of labyrinth and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education credits window
i'd like to now welcome our speaker paul
derose phd
senior bioanalytical chemist at the
national institute of standards and
technology
paul you may now begin your presentation
uh hi i'm paul derose and i'd like to
thank thermal fisher for
inviting me to speak today i'll be
talking about
uh nist assignments of erf fluorescence
intensity
values of calibration microspheres for
quantitative flow cytometry
and and more recently we're expanding
these assignments
to more colors and smaller particles
first i have to show this disclaimer the
top disclaimer is thermofishers the
bottom is nists
and i should mention that nist was
provided by materials
by thermo fisher scientific to support
the work presented here
so the collaboration between nist and
thermo fisher is a long one
we've been collaborating with the
protein and cell analysis business unit
for uh more than 20 years
developing fluorescence intensity
reference materials
and microsphere calibration standards
for flow cytometry
more recently we've had a crada with
thermo fisher
for assigning erf intensity and particle
concentration assignments
of cell size micro particles we assign
more than 25 different fluorescence
channels
for flow cytometer calibration and this
was completed towards the end
of 2020 at about that same time we
started a new crater with thermo fissure
where we are presently doing erf
intensity and particle concentration
assignments
a virus size uh or or submicron as
opposed to micron size which would be
cell size
uh micro particles or nano particles
for flow cytometer calibration
and this is ongoing so that the first
thing that we're doing as part of this
new crata
is looking at uh the the virus check kit
beads which are 100 200 and 500
nanometer
polystyrene beads that are
intended to aid in the development of
viral therapies and vaccines
and keep in mind that the
the covin-19 related virus has a
diameter of 100 to 120 nanometers
we believe that these joint efforts will
make an important contribution to
combating the pandemic
and fulfilling our community
responsibilities as leaders in
biotechnology
[Music]
so to give you an introduction a little
introduction to flow cytometry
although most of you may not need it uh
you know you're basically taking
typically a cell suspension
you're putting it through a narrow
channel such that the cells go through
single
file so you're detecting single cells or
particles using light channels
you may be detecting scattering or
fluorescence
and you're counting the number of cells
or particles in a particular
population based on an intensity gate
which defines that population with a
particular light characteristic
and then downstream of the detection
region at least for some instruments
you're able to then
sort cells based on those different
gatings
[Music]
so what are you actually measuring in
flow cytometry well you can measure
forward light scattering which is the
intensity being directly proportional to
size
you can measure side scattering where
which has is related to shape and
internal complexity
or you can measure fluorescence uh we're
going to be concentrating on
fluorescence today
and um with fluorescence you have a
fluorescent
tag which is attached to some biological
moiety
so it's uh typical typically say
antibodies
so so you're using the fluorescence
intensity to count antibodies
or receptors on cells as well as to
quantify
gene expression and we do that by
measuring the mean fluorescence
intensity or mf5 value of a particular
population
the nfi value is directly proportional
to
some biological quantity for instance
the number of antibodies found per cell
the problem is that mfi values are
different
on every instrument and this has to do
with a variety of things mainly that
detection systems every detection system
has a different spectral response
to light and because fluorescence is an
absolute technique
it's not a relative technique say like
absorbance
so how do we overcome this we use
calibration beads
the calibration beads are assigned
fluorescence intensities which are given
by
the calibration b vendors to the
customer
so so you go in you're looking at
different populations of calibration b's
so for any particular channel you have a
set of beads
at different intensities uh for instance
if we look at the center of a green
emission channel
uh each one of those peaks corresponds
to a different
bead population with a different
fluorescence intensity
if we integrate any one of those peaks
we we get an mfi value for that bead
population
if we take the group of those and we
graph them
so we're measuring the mfi value on our
particular instrument
we're putting it on an absolute
fluorescence intensity value shown on
the y-axis
uh which which in our case uh nist is
is is assigning erf values which
stands for equivalent reference
fluorophore units
so we can then calibrate our instrument
the the instrument dependent quantity
mfi
to the instrument independent quantity
erf
and if we have an unknown which which is
shown by the by the x here
uh then you can say say that's a cell
population
you can put that cell population
intensity
which you're measuring as an mfi value
onto an
absolute scale the erf value
[Music]
so just a few more examples here
if we use uh thermo fissure accu check
beads here we have a low intensity bead
a mid intensity bead
and a high intensity b and um and then
we have a cell population
shown in red and we we see that we can
we can either take the three points that
we get
the the low emitted high intensity b
beads
and graph them as we did on the last
slide and then
we can see where the the cell population
intensity falls another way of doing it
instead of using a bunch of points is
only using one point or one calibration
bead and this is called the nearest
neighbor calibration method
where in this case we would take the
bead that's closest in intensity to the
cell population for instance
the mid intensity b and then by using
the ratio
of the erf value to the mfi value for
the mid intensity bead
and then multiplying by the mfi value
for the cell population
we can assign the erf value for
for for the the cell population in this
case it's
a 121 253 erf units
[Music]
so just to give one more example just so
you get the idea
uh here we're using thermo fissure
performance beads at three different
intensities a low amid and a high
intensity
and uh we are uh quantifying the
intensity of
two cell populations one being a
cd19 positive and the other being a cd19
negative cell population
and again we can use the three uh b
calibration b points to see where the
intensities of the cell populations fall
on that calibration line
or we can use the nearest neighbor
approach in this case the
the positive uh population
is closest to the mid intensity uh b
so we would use that to do an assignment
and the uh
for the negative population that's
closest to the low intensity b
so we would use that for the nearest
neighbor assignment so you have these
two different ways to do it
and um so the question you might ask is
well
how do i know which one to use and the
the answer that i would give is that for
most cases you want to use a line
calibration with multiple points
as this will give you a more accurate
result with a better defined uncertainty
but in certain circumstances if you had
say a cell pocket
population with an intensity that was
particularly low
say on the low end of your calibration
line or particularly high on the high
end or beyond of your
calibration line then it might be
more accurate in some cases to use the
nearest neighbor method
so why did this decide to do these erf
assignments this absolute fluorescence
intensity assignment scale in the first
place
and this goes back to it an
interlaboratory study
that was done through isac the
international society for the
advancement of cytometry back in 2016.
and so nist and four different
calibration bead vendors
each did independent erf assignments
using the same
uh beads and and the same reference
fluorophores
that are used to do the erf assignment
and i'll talk a bit more about
the details of that later but but the
the gist here is that there was poor
agreement between
the uh the participants and um
and this poor poor agreement and we're
not talking about
you know say a factor of two we're
talking about orders of magnitude of
disagreement
and and so this this poor agreement led
the the bead vendors to to strongly
support
a b calibration service that would be
offered by nist
[Music]
so nist offers a variety of services to
our customers
we we produce reference materials
through the office of reference
materials
we we also offer calibration
services where nist is thought of as the
expert
on on a particular measurement we
decided to do
these erf value assignments through
craters
uh individual crates with nist and a
particular stakeholder
say an individual bead vendor and the
reason why we decided to do it that way
is that the crater would enable us to
address the unique needs of into of
individual stakeholders
uh because every stakeholder had
slightly different
needs and it's also
not an exercise where nist is looked at
as the expert but it's actually a
learning curve for both
nist and the stakeholder nist
lending our measurement science
expertise
and the stakeholder lending to nist
their expertise in
in making calibration beads as well as
applications that are needed by their
customers
so who are the who are the stakeholders
who who have we've been working with
over the past few years
to to better quantify
flow cytometry and our collaborators
have included
stakeholder representative organizations
such as nih
fda isac and the international society
for extracellular vesicles
we've also done erf assignments for a
variety of calibration bead vendors
including dd beckman coulter
thermo fisher bangs labs spherotech and
boston cell standards
and we've also worked with other
stakeholders including those in clinical
testing labs such as at
tufts medical center and the canadian
immunohistochemistry
qc laboratory we've also worked
with more than 16 biopharmaceutical
companies
who are interested in monitoring their
online water
which they use to make their
biopharmaceuticals and the idea is that
they
they don't want to have um microbes in
that water
because it obviously could affect uh
the effectiveness and the shelf life of
their of their pharmaceuticals
we've also worked with other
collaborators for other types of
quantitative applications
including bio legends fluidum and ibsc
and lgc we've also been involved in the
development of documentary standards
such as the clsi standard
guidance document h62 for validation of
assays performed by flow cytometry
as well as the usp chapter 127
for flow cytometric enumeration of cd34
positive cells
[Music]
so how exactly does this do an
erf fluorescence intensity assignment of
calibration beads
well it's a two-step process that the
bead vendor sends us their calibration
beads
uh in a in a bead suspension
and we take that bead suspension and do
two measurements on it
the first measurement shown at the top
is a fluorescence intensity measurement
where we where we relate the
fluorescence intensity of the bead
to the fluorescence intensity of a
reference fluorophore solution
and then shown at the bottom we also do
a measurement of the uh number
concentration of the bead suspension
so we put these two values together and
we get an erf
intensity assignment per bead the three
references shown at the right in blue
uh get go into more detail on exactly
how we've done this
and the most recent one which came out
the end of last year
appeared in the journal materials is is
probably the most
current and the most detailed so
what these erf assignments give us are
our fluorescence intensity values for a
particular
procytometer fluorescence channel under
a specified set of instrument conditions
and these erf values are comparable
between instruments and over time
even when different manufacturers
calibration beats are used
so we're basically going from beads that
are
instrument dependent before they're
they're assigned erf values
to to an instrument to a to values that
are instrument
[Music]
independent
[Music]
so first we're going to take a little
closer look at the fluorescence
intensity measurement
we do this on a fluorescent spectrometer
not a flow cytometer
and what we measure is the fluorescence
intensity of a reference solution
there are four reference solutions shown
here which are part of srm1934
and we compare the fluorescence
intensity of one of these reference
solutions
to to the the bead suspension
calibration bead intensity
so for instance if 10 to the fifth
molecules
of a reference fluorophore fluoresce
with the same fluorescence intensity
as one calibration bead then we can say
that that calibration bead
has an erf intensity value of 10 to the
fifth
erf units
so we're using a uh a nist home built
fluorescent spectrometer that's
calibrated
created for spectral shape and linearity
which gives us corrective spectra for
both the
reference solution and the calibration b
so there's a an example shown in the
graph here
we have nile red as a reference
fluorophore
and we have a percy p labeled b that
we're assigning
so we measure the two spectra and we
then
um integrate the spectra over the uh
the bandpass filter spectral region that
would be used on your particular flow
cytometer
and and that gives us two intensities uh
that are
that are equivalent to the intensity
that you would measure on a flow
cytometer
[Music]
so we compare those two values
uh we we have a a serial dilution of the
reference floor for solution
and as shown with the the blue points
here the blue points give us a
calibration line of fluorescence
intensity
in terms of reference floor for
concentration
so so it's important to note here that
erf actually expresses fluorescence
intensity in terms
of reference floor for concentration so
it's not
actually a what you would typically
think of as a fluorescence intensity
and and uh we then take the the bead
suspension intensity put that on our
calibration line
and are able to deduce the fluorescence
and intensity of the bead in terms of
the reference floor for concentration
so uh we have four dyes which make up
srm 1934
coumarin 30 which covers blue emission
fluorescein which covers green emission
nile red orange emission and apc
red emission and one die covers a
particular spectral region
with multiple uh fluorescence channels
so so you don't need a 404
a reference floor for for every every
channel
or for every floor every fluorophore
that you would need on a bead
and this is an important point which
differs it from from mesf for instance
we also measure the bead number
concentration the primary method that we
use is light obscuration and
at least for micron size particles and
we decided to use light
obscuration because it's a it's a simple
technique you're basically looking at a
dip in
the laser intensity as a particle passes
through the laser
and um what's great about this technique
is because it's so simple we can easily
get at the uncertainties that are
involved in the technique
and therefore can specify what those
uncertainties are
we've shown this technique to be an si
traceable
particle counting technique which has
been
shown in detail in the in the reference
shown at the bottom
in blue which appeared in 2018.
[Music]
we also use other techniques to support
these measurements
kind of as a as a reality check we we
always use flow cytometry
to back to back up the light obscuration
measurements
uh we used uh true count b's as an
internal standard in that case
and we've also used the quilter counter
to uh to compare measurements
and when we do compare the measurements
we we find the values to agree within
about five percent
so what what are the final values that
we give to our customers
we give erf values with total
uncertainties reported
the erf values are in most cases are si
traceable
and the total uncertainty that we give
is a two sigma ninety-five percent
confidence level uncertainty which
has ranged from about five percent to
thirteen percent
we also give each customer a nist
certificate
this is an official nist document which
uh
tells the the erf value for a particular
bead and fluorescence
channel and the related uncertainty
[Music]
so one thing i wanted to emphasize here
is that
once we have erf values for calibration
beads
we've put those fluorescence intensities
onto an absolute
scale but it's an absolute fluorescence
intensity scale
it is not an absolute biological scale
so still to put the erf value scale
to put the erf scale onto an absolute
biological scale say antibodies down per
cell
we still need at least one biological
standard
which is shown here we're using one
biological standard to
to put erf shown on the left axis to abc
on the right axis
we've expanded the number of reference
fluorophores that we've
that we use for assignments beyond srm
1934.
uh three new ones include pacific orange
which uh uses the same excitation
wavelengths as coomer
30 but goes further into the red side it
goes into yellow green emission
as well as alexa for 700 and alexa for
750 which go further into the near ir
than apc
[Music]
so you remember that i said that you
know we use these reference fluorophores
to express fluorescence intensity of
term in terms of
reference for for concentration in order
to do that we have to determine the
purity of the fluorophores so i just
wanted to give an example of that
with the new dyes so here for instance
is pacific orange
and we initially use hplc kind of as a
quick and dirty to show that it's
it's approximately as pure as we need it
to be to be a reference solution
and a reference floor for so we've using
hplc we found the pacific orange
uh to have a purity of about one percent
an impurity of about one percent so a
purity of about 99
um we then use quantitative proton nmr
as an si traceable purity technique so
this is
really our primary si traceable
technique
for determining purity we use a
nist primary standard for quantitative
nmr
benzoic acid and
some of the issues that we found with
the three new dies
as that we didn't find with the original
four dies in srm 1934
is that the new dyes were very
hydroscopic so we had to do
gravimetry under dry nitrogen which
complicated things a bit
we also found that the the counter ion
and thy molecule ratio was not an
integer for these dyes
and because of that we had to determine
purity for the three new dyes
in terms of grams of dye molecule per
gram
of solid sample as opposed to say
say moles of of dye
per sample which we which we were able
to do for the original srm1934
we also found that the the impurity
values that we found for quantitative
nmr
were significantly higher than what the
hplc
implied and uh we saw as much as
six percent for pacific orange four
percent for alexa for seven hundred and
thirteen percent for the explorer seven
fifty and uh because of these
discrepancies between the hplc and the
quantitative nmr
we do have high confidence as to the
accuracy of the quantitative proton nmr
technique in this case but since we
don't know what is causing this
discrepancy what are the unknowns that
we
haven't identified the the values the
purity values become reference values
instead of certified values
a certified value being a higher level
of confidence
according to this criteria
[Music]
so here are all the dyes here's our
palette of colors or reference
fluorophores
that we're we've used to this point the
uh
the larger peaks being the fluorescence
emission spectrum
of each dye which defines the the floor
four channels the fluorescence channels
that we can cover using a particular
reference four or four
and then the the smaller peaks are the
absorbance spectra for each of the dyes
which defines which laser wavelength or
wavelengths
would be used to excite that particular
reference die
what we want to do in the future is
really cover all
of the fluorescence channels that are
available on on flow cytometers
so we want to go further into the into
the uv
on the left side and further into the
near ir
on the right side as well as maybe
filling in some gas in the middle
and where we are working on that
and this is just a a tabular
format of what you just saw in the graph
[Music]
so i wanted to give you an idea of the
different fluorescence channels that
we've covered
to this point so i listed all of them
and um
using coomer 30 as a reference floor
we've assigned 10 different fluorescent
channels using pacific orange
we've assigned six different
fluorescence channels using fluorescein
we've assigned eight channels
using nile red at 488 excitation
we've assigned seven channels
[Music]
using nile red at 561 nanometer
excitation we've assigned 10 channels
using apc we've assigned six and using
alexa core 700
we've assigned four channels
so in summary of all the erf assignments
that we've done to this point
we've assigned more than 50 fluorescence
channels using
five lasers six are now available to us
with emission ranging from 390
nanometers to 850 nanometers
using six reference four fours seven are
now available to us
and we've covered diameters of
calibration b's from two microns
to ten microns
so where are we going next next we're
going to smaller sizes
we we want to characterize some micron
or
or nanometer sized particles in a
similar way
this is of great interest because of the
study of extracellular vesicles and
viruses
which have diameters that typically
range from 40 nanometers to 1000
nanometers
evs in particular are thought to mediate
intracellular communications in
physiology and pathology
and many of the same surface receptors
as
cells are found on evs so this is
because of that this is a topic of
growing interest
in flow cytometry now in principle the
same approach
that was used to do eras assignments
for micron-sized particles can also be
used for nanometer-sized particles
the problem is that uh there aren't
techniques that have been well
established to be to be
accurate measures of b number
concentration so it's not the
fluorescence intensity measurement
that we see as the problem here it's the
b number concentration
and uh the the few examples that you
find in the literature
such as electron microscopy tend to be
very time consuming
and very difficult and very expensive so
we need some easier more user-friendly
[Music]
techniques
and before i go on to speak about that a
little bit more i just wanted to
acknowledge the people
who have participated and and contribute
to these
ers assignments at nist uh
this includes lily wong dolph gangulus
linguatian dean ripple saunder da silver
and nancy lin
we are also uh dolph gagless has done
modeling of antibody binding
and the quantitative proton nmr was done
by aaron ervis and mike nelson
and we also have groups at nist which
meet periodically
where we have particle counting
discussions and
also sub micron b number concentration
measurement discussions and
the this ladder group is also doing
all the measurements that i'll be
talking about next
so as i said at the beginning the the
first nanometer size particles that
we'll be looking at
is part of the virus check kit from
thermo fisher
and this kit is is meant to aid in
um in looking at uh and the development
of viral therapeutic and vaccine
investigations by helping to improve
flow cytometry assay accuracy and
efficiency
ensure intra and interlaboratory data
comparison
and to improve day-to-day
reproducibility
the profoto the proposed virus check kit
is comprised of five different
components
each of them is a half a milliliter uh
bead suspension with a concentration of
five times ten to the six
beads per mil the five components
are three 100 nanometer beads labeled
with fitzy like
pe like and apc like uh fluorophores
and then we have 200 nanometer bead and
a 500 nanometer bead that are
labeled with multiple dyes uh so-called
uh
beads
[Music]
so what what are the uh the different
techniques that we're looking at at nist
well we're looking at electron
microscopy particularly sem
now i i did say this is this is probably
the most difficult
and time consuming but but to this point
it's
kind of been looked at as the gold
standard so we thought we should
definitely include it as a comparison
it gives accurate core sizes and
relative number concentrations but
doing absolute concentration
measurements
is very difficult
[Music]
we're looking at uh asymmetrical flow
fuel flow fractionation with dynamic
light scattering detection
af4 is used to separate particles by
size
the af4 allows the dynamic light
scattering
measurement to be more accurate and
and some of the problems that you have
with af4 is
with dls is that relative number of
populations are biased toward larger
particles
drf is dls is also not quantitative for
absolute number concentration
but af4 can be confined combined with
other detection techniques such as uv
absorbance
and multi-angle scattering to make
number
concentration more quantitative so we're
working on that
[Music]
we're also looking at nanoparticle
tracking analysis or nta
it's an optical method which which takes
snapshots of moving particles in
solution
it's an optical method which measures
the hydrodynamic
radius of particles
one of the problems is that you need a
number concentration reference standard
for an accurate absolute measurement and
large particles mask
the detection efficiency of smaller
particles in mixtures
we're also looking at resistive pulse
sensing or rps
also known as a quilter counter which
gives accurate size diameters and
relative number concentration
but again it needs a number
concentration reference standard
to do absolute measurements and the size
limit here is about 200 nanometers so
you can't go below 200 nanometers
their so-called next generation rps
which
which can use mother microfluidics and
other techniques to get to smaller
um microliter sample sizes
and and also to get to smaller diameters
as low as 60 nanometers again
the same same problem arises you need a
number concentration reference standard
to do absolute measurements
[Music]
we're also looking at nano and quantum
flow cytometers
we have one that was built at nist and
the size it promises size limits of 30
nanometers or smaller
but these are not commercially available
and we don't have enough data
to say much at this point about accuracy
there are also virus counters the one
that we have at nist
is basically a specialized flow
cytometer with two fluorescent channels
it's designed for virus detection it's
it's meant to handle size range from
about 25 nanometers to 300 nanometers
and one of its advantages is it measures
volume in real time
uh we don't again we don't have enough
data to say how well it will do with
detecting beads and and also how
accurate is
is the real-time volume measurement
[Music]
and then the last technique that we're
looking at to this point
uh is a is a type of fluorescence
microscopy where we use
charged slides with so that the uh the
beads or particles stick
to the slides and uh combined with a
more accurate
way to do sample volume determinations
and that this is a similar to the way
you would use a hemocytometer
but it gives greater accuracy precision
and speed
and um and the size limit here is about
80 nanometers
uh we have one at nist but it's not
commercially available
[Music]
and then here's basically a summary of
everything i just said about the
different techniques
uh going over each technique specifying
the size limit and size range uh
the the optimum sample volume for the
particular technique
the optimal concentration range for the
technique
and and caveats
[Music]
so so far we've looked at numbers from
five of these techniques
we've compared them uh looking at a
hundred nanometer and two hundred
nanometer beads
right now we're seeing an agreement
within a factor of two
but uh that's not good enough i'd say we
would like to go
say under 30 uncertainties
uh you know so we're working to
eliminate bias
in the different techniques and
understand the uncertainties
involved in each of them
so the important developments here
is that flow cytometry quantitation
the the consortium and and the craters
that we've developed bring stakeholders
together
uh for to develop measurement services
reference materials reference data
and reference methods and
this is a nist in nih co-managed
consortium
i should also mention that the that the
flow cytometry quantitation
consortium has recently just been
replaced by the flow cytometry standards
consortium
where we're expanding the scope of the
consortium
beyond erf measurements
uh nist is performing erf assignments of
calibration
b's through kratos we're adding more
reference dies and laser colors to
assign erf values for all fluorescence
channels
that are available on all flow
cytometers that's our ultimate goal
with the with the graph at least
we're also working with stakeholders to
determine number concentrations
of submicron bioparticles and assign erf
values
to sub micron calibration beads
so one of the ways that we're trying to
expand our scope
is to consider antibody reagent quality
and there there was a report that came
out from a working group
that appeared in nature methods in
september of 2016 which reported that
that there at the time were 300
companies that sell antibodies
there's probably more now and uh
antibody reagent quality was found to be
inconsistent
and sometimes poor and many clinical
diagnostics and therapies rely on such
antibody reagents
so it was estimated that more than 800
million dollars per year is wasted due
to
poor quality antibodies and what was
suggested
to going forward is that what was needed
are reagent and documentary standards to
help determine quality
and ensure reproducibility
so part of our expansion of scope
includes
uh opening up fluorescence and other
types of measurements
in order to um to care to better
characterize antibody reagents
including looking at fluorescence
quantum yields fluorescence lifetimes
and corrective fluorescence spectra
we're doing thermodynamic modeling of
antibody binding characteristics
we also would like to do a flow
cytometry
standardization round robin where we
look at erf assignments
of reference cells
just some of the things that we have in
the pipeline
and uh with that i thank you for your
attention and would be
happy to take any of your questions
thank you paul for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question
is
to estimate antibodies bound per cell i
believe
it is important to have a one to one
fluorophore to protein ratio
when you use other fluorochromes how
does this compute
i i mean i i would say that you know if
if you know right the number of
fluorophores
um per antibody that helps to get you to
some biological quantity
but it you know but it's not it's not
necessary just to do a calibration of
your instrument
so it depends on what you're trying to
achieve with with your calibration beads
um uh
yeah i guess you can you can certainly
i mean that's part of why we're doing
modeling antibody
modeling so that we have a better
understanding
of how exactly is is fluorescence
intensity related with the number of
antibodies that are there
and and even for for simple cases
it's not totally straightforward um to
to assign a biological quantity
using using a bead uh because
you know the the the bead chemistry and
the
and the the biological say the cell
chemistry
can be quite different uh you know also
some bees are hard dyed some bees are
surface labeled
you know hard diabetes are probably
aren't
particularly useful to get biological
quantities
but but surface labeled beets may be
more useful in that way if you
have an understanding of things like you
like you said
the number of floors per antibody
thank you paul our next question can you
explain again
how this differs from any mesf beads
uh yes um right so so mess
which stood for molecules of equivalent
soluble
four four fluorochrome as opposed to erf
which is equivalent reference
fluorophores
uh the difference is that mesf is a
special case or
subset of erfs so mes
nesf means that the reference 404 and
the bead 4 for
the same so so the two fluorophores
for erfs in contrast cover the same
spectral range
but don't have to be the same dye
so so ers is a more practical choice
because you don't need a different floor
for for every existing fluorescent label
uh you know there are hundreds
of fluorescent labels and it you know so
it's impractical and it's certainly not
within
this nist's budget to to do that even if
it was possible even if it was
chemically possible with which in some
cases
not
thank you paul our next question here is
you presented the inter-laboratory
performance study done in 2018.
can you discuss studies done since or
planned
that will address the value of erf
assignments to improve the fi
reproducibility issues
um or fl probably fluorochrome
chloride or fluorochrome reproducibility
reproducibility issues um
i mean i mean we we are we are doing
additional studies um
i'm not sure what what the question is
referring to as far as
fluorescence intensity reproducibility
issues like i guess they're talking
about the study
so right so that right right so they're
right they're saying
that uh you know are we trying to
make uh materials available so that
people can actually
do their own erf assignments i mean
that's what we tried to do in the
this original study and and that's why
nist is doing the assignments
because there was there was too much
disagreement and
um and we also did identify some
systematic errors
in in in the um
[Music]
in in the the the approaches of other
laboratories
but um yeah i mean
you know i i i don't i don't see
the you know at least not in the
near-term
uh you know a lot of other people doing
ers assignments besides
nist even though it certainly is
possible and we encourage people to
attempt it
uh but but um you know
i think what we are doing is we're we're
encouraging
uh we want to do a round robin where we
take
calibration beads we pass them around
and make sure that
that different calibration beads can
give the same answer on on different
instruments and um because that that to
me
is is the most important thing that we
have to show it's the whole purpose of
the erf assignments
so so until everybody can do that easily
you know i think that's the priority
thank you paul and i believe the
questioner
has just clarified his question
have other interlab studies been done
with erf to improve
uh we we are working with certain
laboratories
uh who are interested in doing their own
erf
assignments uh but we so far we've been
doing that on a one-on-one basis
because because at least to this point
there didn't seem
like a large interest from the original
participants to
to uh to quickly do this kind of
round robin again
okay thank you paul and our next
question here
can i use accu-chek erf particles as
intensity reference for a spectral flow
cytometer
i have a scitec aurora
uh yes the the answer is yes
as long as the spectral range used to
determine the fluorescence intensity is
the same
for the spectral flow cytometer uh and
the
calibration b so you want to make sure
that your
your um you know if you have a spectrum
then you have to integrate over a
particular
gate that you choose to to define a
fluorescence intensity
and that gate just has to be consistent
uh between the instrument and then the
bead
thank you paul i have time for a few
more questions
can i use erf particles to compare
exosome data
uh the answer is yes uh that's why nist
wants to assign erf values to smaller
beads
if you use cell size or micron size
beads
for your exosome assignments you're
you're going to get inaccuracy
um i i i don't even think that
that level of inaccuracy uh is
is completely understood or has been
um you know has has been shown
exactly what it is but but but certainly
uh even theoretically it it uh
we don't expect it to be as accurate as
it would be
if you had micron size
beads to do the calibration
all right and we've got one more
question do erf
bees replace mesf beads
uh i i mean i guess that that question i
guess is similar to i guess what it was
the first question
uh um i mean i guess i already explained
the difference between
mesf and erf i i mean the simple
answer to that question is yes you know
i think uh
you know for all the reasons i stated
just because of the the practicality
of using erf versus trying to have a
bead for every
um a different reference floor for for
every type of fluorescent label
that you would find on a bead or a cell
thank you paul do you have any final
comments for our audience today
uh i i think i you know i as you saw
from our
um from the acknowledgements you know
there's a lot of people at nist working
on this we also have
a lot of collaboration with people
outside of nist
particularly looking at at the
sub-micron regime
and um you know so we're excited about
this work
and we we expect to have some
some some good results in the in the
near term
uh you know i would also uh you know
like to thank again everyone who
who came attended the talk today and
if you have any further questions uh
that pop up uh you're welcome to email
me
um my my uh my email is on
is on the nist website and and it's uh
it's also just
firstname.lastname.nist.gov so
so thanks a lot thank you again paul for
your time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank labrus and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you're provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye